Hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide. Today I'm going to be
showing you how I made 550k
in 10 minutes. Now this method is
restricted by the buying limit. So you
can only do this about every 4 hours. Uh
but super safe. Uh you do need at least
maybe 10 mil to start doing this. Uh but
no skill requirements. All going to be
done at the Grand Exchange and again
extremely safe. All right, let's get
started. All right, what we're going to
be doing today is actually something
kind of cool I found just by looking at
the wiki. Wiki's got some really good
information, guys. So, don't ignore it.
Let's have a look at what we got for you
today. So, what we're going to do is
dismantle magic fangs and any of the
Zora drops into Zor scales and just
reseller scales. Uh, so we have a quick
look at the wiki. I just noticed this
little section at the bottom. It just
shows you you can dismantle the fang for
20,000 scales and profit 22k. Uh, so not
bad. Let's go ahead and give it a try.
Uh let's first calculate to see how
profitful it's going to be. So we have G
Tracker open uh with the Serpentine
Visage and the Magic Fang. Link will be
in the description for G Tracker if you
want to sign up for an account. Anyway,
so let's go ahead and look at the most
current price here. So looks to be quite
low around 20 uh 2.6 mil. That looks
pretty promising because if we take the
price of the Zolver scale, we'll go have
a quick look at the Zver scale quickly.
Might as well just buy it here.
Zra scale. It's usually around 135 or
134. 135. So that's pretty good.
So if we open up G Tracker, take a
calculator. So we're going to get 20,000
skills. So that's 135 * 20,000
giving us 2.7 mil. We take off our
approximate buy price of 2.6 mil.
We're left with about 100K in profit off
that item.
That sounds really easy. Let's go ahead
and put an offer in for some serpentine
visages.
Serpentine
visage.
Uh we'll try for 26
09k.
And uh the binding limit on these
unfortunately is five. And that's why I
kind of feel like uh this method can
still be sustained because the buying
limit is so low. You can only do about
five of these every 4 hours. All right.
Now, let's move on to the other item,
which I think would be good, is the
magic fang. Looks like on the wiki, it's
saying we're profiting about 22k. Uh,
the magic fang looks like it's around
2641.
Not as profitable, but still nothing to
scoff at. That's still 50 60k for doing
absolutely nothing. All right, so about
26 40. Let's do magic fang.
41k and uh we'll do five of those.
All right, guys. So, we'll come back
when these items have bought and we'll
see how much we actually profit from
dismantling them. All right, so we're
back and uh we successfully bought all
the visages and the fangs. Under 10
minutes to buy all of those guys. Really
easy. you could stand to profit quite a
bit more if you left that in overnight,
which I didn't mean to. Uh, but you get
the point. Uh, if you left that in
overnight, you may have been able to buy
10 if you're lucky. So, go ahead and
collect all the offers. Collect item
just so we can dismantle it. View offer
and collect item. Just before
dismantling, I'm just going to recheck
the Zoro scale margin. Uh, and guys, if
the Zoro scales somehow really tanked
it, uh, like they're selling for 133
now,
probably worth waiting to sell. 133 *
20,000
is 2660. So, you really want to sell
them for the 135. But that being said,
if the Zoro scales really tank it, just
flip the item. I mean, it's not a huge
loss. Uh, but we'll go ahead and pop
them in for 135 and we'll just wait.
Anyway, what we're going to do is uh
dismantle all of them. Yes.
Dismantle.
Yes. Dismantle.
Yes. So, right now, we're getting a load
of dissolver scales. Also, if you need
dollar scales, this is kind of a way to
get around the binding limit as well. Uh
probably would never be that big an
issue, but look, we're about to get 200k
uh solver scales pretty easily here.
But, we want to definitely wait for the
135 price. At worst, we want to sell
them for 134. But I think if we wait,
uh, we should hopefully get it sold for
this price.
All right, so 200k is dollar scales.
Going to pop them in there for 135.
And that's going to be 27 mil we're
selling it for. All right, guys. Going
to leave it in here for a little while
and we'll come back uh when they have
sold. Okay, so we did manage to sell
these skills for 134. So, we didn't
quite get 135, meaning we lost out on
200k in profit, uh, we were looking to
get about 750K in profit, but since we
sold them for 1GP lower, that's going to
be 549K. Still 550k in 10 minutes work.
Uh, the silver scales, all 200k sold in
like 3 minutes. Extremely easy once we
adjusted the prices. And, uh, yeah,
let's go ahead claim our offer here and
just double check what we're at. So, we
start at 30 mil and after uh that
moneymaking/flip is done, we're at 550k.
Can't say enough how easy this was. Of
course, you always want to check the
prices. Uh if we have a look at the
price of uh Zoler scales, uh this is
only really possible currently because
the prices for Zoler scales are up.
They're up to about 135. And if we have
a look at the price of the serpentine
visage, it is actually up as well. So,
interesting. So, it looks like this
might be profitable more often. Uh cuz
the uh price of this helm used to be
much lower. But that being said, h you
don't do want to check the prices ahead
of time, especially the price of the
Zoro scale cuz that even one GP uh
difference can really add up to a lot of
your profit being ate up. So, yeah. Hope
you guys enjoyed the money-making
method. If you did, toss the video a
like and I will see you guys in the next
video.
[Music]